so we have an opportunity here to do a
little bit of uh of learning of
education about how our electoral system
works and some of the nuances and
particulars that some of us may may not
be familiar with uh
the story about mike pence's possible
role in the 2020 election
is again just front and center
as donald trump's new spokeswoman liz
harrington posted to twitter
a statement from trump
going after mike pence saying pence
could have turned over the election if
he wanted and essentially given it to
trump the statement put out yesterday
from trump reads
if the vice president mike pence had
quote absolutely no right to change the
presidential election results in the
senate despite fraud and many other
irregularities how come the democrats
and rhino republicans like wacky susan
collins are desperately trying to pass
legislation that will not allow the vice
president to change the results of the
election
actually what they are saying is that
mike pence did have the right to change
the outcome and they now want to take
that right away unfortunately he didn't
exercise that power he could have
overturned the election now
it's not true
that the laws that are being proposed
about the vice president's role are
because the vice president could
overturn the election it's almost like
there's so many ignorant people that
falsely think the vice president can
just decide who wins
that they're looking at putting
something
more basic in writing to that end but we
actually have an infrastructure of law
already that makes it very clear that
the vice president's role with the
electoral college is just opening the
envelopes literally and figuratively and
we're going to get to that but think
about what they're saying i mean if if
what trump is saying is correct it means
kamala harris could choose the winner of
the 2024 election she doesn't like who
the person that supposedly won
kamala could say nope somebody else won
and of course that's not the case
the truth is
that
uh the vice president does not have the
power to do any of the things that
donald trump has hoped that pence would
have done including you know seating an
alternate slate of electors from certain
states or any such thing
the 12th amendment governs this
really really clearly and you can just
google 12th amendment and read the
entire thing uh it's not very long but
the the important relevant points here
are that the 12th amendment says the
electors shall meet
in their respective states and vote by
ballot for president and vice president
they shall name in their ballots the
person voted for as president okay fair
the president of the senate meaning the
vice remember
the vp of the u.s is the president of
the senate the president of the senate
shall in the presence of the senate and
house meaning a joint session
open all the certificates and the votes
shall then be counted
that says nothing about
evaluate whether this is the correct
slate of electors it's
the vp
shall open the certificates
and the votes shall then be counted
doesn't even say the vice president will
be doing the counting the votes shall be
counted the person having the greatest
number of votes for president shall be
the president that's it
you then have in addition to the 12th
amendment the electoral count act of
1887. now why in 1887 well uh in 1876
there was a disputed election and in the
roughly 9 10 11 years that followed
the electoral count act of 1887 was put
together it also is very clear it number
one puts the onus of resolving disputes
to the states if there are disputes the
state resolves the disputes not the
federal government or the congress so
for example
if a governor from arizona
certified two different slates of
electors right they sign off on some
democratic electors and then a slate of
republican electors
that would be a real problem uh if a
state just doesn't certify any electors
that would be a problem that
would come to congress but 90
of that is states handle these issues
now if you have one of these extenuating
circumstances where the federal
government gets involved there's a few
things congress can do
if there's a ministerial error
if there's an elector sent who's not
eligible to be an elector for some
reason if there's a candidate
certified who isn't eligible to be
president
um
those would be reasons why congress can
get involved it's very clearly
very limited and to deviate from that
requires powers that the vice president
doesn't have it depends on the house and
senate it's and that's where all of this
stuff comes from uh a member of the
house would stand and object and then
they need a member of the senate to
stand and object with them et cetera so
the story that they're telling is an ex
it's not only a dangerous story uh it's
also an untrue story and what we're up
against is that in march
trump and pence are both speaking back
to back nights at a republican committee
event
in new orleans louisiana and it'll be
very interesting to see if there
trump also slams pence and what the
crowd reaction would be is something i
would want to see as well
i am someone who loves documentaries i
would imagine many of you love them as
well you've got to check out our sponsor
curiosity stream it's the only streaming
platform
dedicated to documentaries i'm always
noticing curiosity stream has the best
selection of documentaries better than
netflix or any other platform and the
best part is it's only 15 bucks a year
when you click the link below and use
the code pacman which is an amazing deal
it's nearly endless documentary content
and whether you want to tune out and
watch something relaxing dive into
something really thought provoking
curiosity stream has both and everything
in between
i just got done watching pompeii
which is unbelievable i visited pompeii
when i was in italy and the documentary
filled in so much fascinating history
about it and the people who lived there
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 off a subscription that comes out to
14.99 a year a year go to
curiositystream.compacman
and use the code pacman the link is down
below